I called ministers to to come to
Brussels to cover a few important
aspects that we still have to deal in
the area reform these important aspects
cover for example the relationship in
between the Commission and and in SM we
need clarity in the complement and
complementarity in both institutions
role in our improved
institutional design this is very
important because you know the
Commission is responsible for
multilateral surveillance for some
aspects that you just asked me on Italy
but both institutions will be
responsible to deal with crisis
management in the future but we also
have in our agenda another important
aspect which is the contribution of
France and Germany on the zone budget it
is an important topic for today's
discussion
these are digitally it's a mission that
is in the ends of the Commission to deal
with at this stage we certainly
following all developments very closely
but we now have to wait until tomorrow
day after tomorrow when the Commission
this is there its opinion on the DB
piece to continue